with the dora milaje i didn't know what  to expect  there's something magical about it all  the wakandans are back and they brought  so much to the party  when we show up you don't know how many  are around  put down the pointy sticks and we can  talk this through there's a confidence  and all us get out of the way yeah  you can only do so much  you should do something  he realizes  how vulnerable he is  is he gonna take the super soldier serum  that decision  is crushing  we're gonna need all hands on deck for  whatever's coming next i'm so excited to  see the outcome we are not spoiling  anything  i'm sure it will all come to an  agreeable conclusion  you